hallo zusammen heutige tour beim letzten
mal habe ich euch die küche gezeigt
jetzt gucken wir was sich hinter dieser
schiebetür verbirgt und es ist so dass
ich das ganze hier vor sechs sieben
monaten noch gar nicht hatte weil das
komplett zu war da waren büroräume und
da ist der mieter als quasi ausgezogen
und wir konnten dann einen durchbruch
machen und haben jetzt zwei extra römer
das heißt ein wohnzimmer und ein büro
bevor wir es aber reinspringen zeige ich
euch wie wir die ganzen möbel ausgesucht
haben dafür waren wir bei möbel hadek in
bochum und das seht ihr jetzt also leute
ganz wichtig ich brauche ein sofa einen
tisch also ein großen esstisch endlich
ich freue mich und ein tv vod lassen so
die drei wichtigsten dinge und ich hoffe
dass ich heute auch fündig werde wir
gucken uns jetzt einfach mal um und wir
im heim vorteil wir sind nämlich bei
möbel habe ich in bochum kaum haben sie
sagt was das was er immer sagt wenn wir
hier vorreiter was man begibt sich
möglich haben sie erzählt immer wenn wir
dran vorbei fand ich super gespielt als
klima sind
[Musik]
also unser jetziges sofa das ist viel zu
klein für das neue wohnzimmer und das
ist halt grau wollen deshalb jetzt gerne
so in richtung ich gehen so eine schöne
warme fahren und da gucke ich mache
etwas passendes dabei ist vorüber grünen
eher grün finde ich gar nicht so
schlecht und ich finde grün auch gar
nicht so übel dieses markt aber ich
würde gerne auch die nach jahreszeit von
bisschen um diverse was ja mach was du
willst haben danke
dieses shoppen mit mir schon
mal aufgefallen das haben wir immer
macht macht warum hast du jetzt ein core
temp ich weiß nicht ob das an gezogen
ich habe das zuerst eingezogen also
früher habe ich das gefühl hatte jeder
eine eckbank zu hause am esstisch und
ganz ehrlich ich cool haben wir sonst
mit banken ich auch also es ist schön
wenn man nur die küchentheke und wir
essen unser mittagessen schon auf einem
sofa also ich bin dafür große esstisch
der für die ganze familie groß genug ist
nur ansatzweise so gemütlich ist wie die
aussieht dann schlaf ich von nun an auf
dieser bank du musst auch auf die beine
achten also eigentlich müssen wir uns
erst vom sofa entscheiden und dann legen
sie parallel esstisch mit passenden
weinen zu denen zudem wurde
[Musik]
meine frau meine frau ist schwanger nein
spaß
ist noch zeit für leute über zeit immer
piano der kleiner fragt hundert meter
von hier man kann es fast sehen ist die
wohnung von hans eltern wurde haben sie
aufgewachsen ist dort in haben das
jugendzimmer 30 quadratmeter haben wir
unseren shop gestartet und so durfte ich
einfach
wirklich kann ich freue mich immer das
ist als würde ich hier verwandte und
freunde treffen
viele machen den fehler und kaufen dann
alles auf einmal ich nehme nur die
essentiellen sachen also ich werde nur
die essentiellen sachen erstmal kaufen
dann warte ich tatsächlich die lieferung
ab und dann kümmere ich mich um platinen
pouch tischdeko deko kauf ich sowieso
erst ganz zum schluss ich hab echt
gelernt man sollte wirklich warten und
wirklich 23 mal gucken was man braucht
viva schafft 100 meter vom öl-leck
entfernt wohnt meine schwiegermama
familie und haben so wir haben doch
hunger oder wie immer und immer kurz so
gut und dann hoffen
wir es befreien wie es geht
[Musik]
gut den markt oh mein gott ich bin nun
diese so schnell aus dem bett
aufgestanden heute kommt unsere möbel
leute dieser raum der ist seit februar
frei seit februar ist ist so ist zum
greifen nah wird ich denke die ganze
hinter diesen trend bewegt befindet sich
mein wohnzimmer arbeitete mein
essbereich und es hat sich so gezogen
aufgrund der aktuellen situation zum
glück ging das mit den möbeln recht fix
also das sind den möbeln ging echt echt
fix mit hadek muss ich sagen da bin ich
total positiv begeistert weil hecht es
noch lange warten müssen ich glaube ich
wir also ich bin ein sehr ungeduldiger
mensch
ich freue mich
[Musik]
der verstand und herz ja hast du unsere
achtung gefühl wenn die dann entstehende
ok habe ich mir das wichtige auf diesem
ist die wandfarbe die richtige ist die
rose ist jetzt größer oder mit
guckt mal dass es mit dem vermieter
abgesprochen gewesen ist extra
stromkabel jene mitte des raumes dann
haben sondern ich wollte mir gern sind
arbeitsplatz haben wir uns gegenüber
sitzen dass er keine wand anstarren
damit war kein kabelsalat haben geht das
jetzt hier quasi und dann komme ich
gleich die bei tische hin noch ist es
nackig aber nicht mehr lange leute
[Musik]
ich komme so den raum rein auf einmal
steht dieses wunderschöne teil da
also ja haben sie es auch in das schöne
hier ja ok
[Musik]
aber soll ich eigentlich guck mal ich
sagt wie es ist eigentlich wollte ich
mir alles nicht angucken sondern es
steht völlig gewahrt und das so gut aus
es gehe ich erstmal hier die playstation
5 abgeben bei der post die hat nämlich
eine ganze wand in bei unserem 250.000
abonnenten special auf instagram
gewonnen das schicke ich jetzt ab und
dann komme ich auch schon wieder zurück
[Musik]
der mauve doch den ich gewartet habe
die monteure waren übrigens super
sympathisch dem so schnell gearbeitet
und ja nicht liegen lassen dem alles an
verpackungsmaterial dem alles ressorts
mitgenommen filz auf dem boden ausgelegt
damit der boden keine kratzer bekommt
also top top top wirklich so hansering
jetzt muss die leisten
[Musik]
hallo willkommen zu einem neuen tag
irgendwie dabei habe und jetzt gucken
wir uns nach deckung und micoud ich
brauche ich noch ein tägliches hatte
habe und dann wird euch jetzt mit
[Musik]
das sofa steht ja schon
couchtisch haben wir jetzt auch ein
gefunden bzw eine kombination und jetzt
brauche ich halt noch einen passenden
teppich hallo
hier ist eine tür da geht es dann raus
und dann habt ihr in einen schwarzen
wir holen uns jetzt gleich noch mal das
stoffmuster von der couch ich rate euch
auch immer wenn ihr möbelhaus nimmt das
stoffmuster mitbringt zwar natürlich
auch wieder zurück und guckt dann welche
sind wirklich besser teppich passt dazu
weil man kauft es einmal und dann steht
das zuhause dann sollte es auch farblich
passen was genau so und da haben wir
keinen kopf mehr dass sie täglich und
dafür ist wir haben
[Musik]
ich war mir schon fast nicht mehr sicher
sobald man hier steht vergisst man schon
fast wie die farbe genau aber das ist
mal ganz gut wenn man dann alles quasi
aus einem haus holen
sona resources
schwiegermama
bis zu dem zeitpunkt war alles noch sehr
nackig aus wie es jetzt aussieht das
gucken uns am besten mal gemeinsam an
kommt mit also ich fange direkt einmal
hier zu meiner rechten an da ist nämlich
unsere sitzgruppe und das war vorher
halt für uns voll die belastende
situation weil vorher hatten wir unser
wohnzimmer in einer ecke der küche und
das war so man hat immer auf die küche
gucken ich liebe meine küche aber ich
muss es nicht abends zum rückgrat
netflix gucken die ganze zeit sehen
also hier finden wirklich alle platz und
das war vorher als drüben sagt weil sie
wohnzimmer und zur ecke hatten ich
konnte gar nicht die ganze familie auf
einmal einladen weil einfach irgendwie
drei von sechs haben sich dann den
rücken gekrümmt was irgendwie auch zum
hocker sitzen mussten und so hat
wirklich jeder platz und weil ich so
viele stühle hat die zeige ich euch
gleich habe ich mich auch für die
sitzbank entschieden und die ist so
gemütlich sitzt auf instagram also
manchmal obwohl wir auch im büro habe
natürlich mit dem laptop und arbeite von
hier aus hier kann man auf jeden fall
stundenlang sitzen würde ich sogar
liegen manchmal nach frischte klicken
ist noch wohin ist auf jeden fall echt
sauer gemütlich so passend zu dieser
bank habe ich auch die stühle da habe
ich mich für drehstühle entschieden und
wissen eigentlich fast schon sessel und
das coole ist sie drehen sich immer
wieder zur ausgangsposition zurück und
auch diesen extrem gemütlich und
allgemein also egal wenn mich hier
besuchen kamen die um alle gesagt hey
ich will hier gar nicht mehr aufstehen
zum tisch das ist ein riesengroßer
marmortisch ich hätte mir auch holz
ausgesucht eventuell ich habe es richtig
gespannt aber weil ich drüben schon holz
habe an der theke hab ich gedacht kommen
hier im wurzeln bleiben wir bei marmor
oder zeige ich euch meine highlights
stühle das ist mein highlight studien
habe ich an beiden enden vom tisch ich
hab zwar einerseits die passende
sitzgruppe andererseits wollte ich aber
so ein bisschen was anderes reinbringen
und da fand ich dass er ganz cool ich
mag auch die optik das ist schwarz matt
da gebe ich dann so ein großes kissen
drauf und dann kann man sich hier auch
noch mal reinsetzen es auch richtig
gemütlich wie oft habe ich jetzt das
wort gemütlich gesagt über am esstisch
habe ich dann eine bubble lampen sondern
ich sie ganz gerne das sind so ganz
viele kleine bubbles und die ist dann
auch das ist so ein schwarz graues glas
es hat mir ganz gut gefallen und das
finden wir gleich auch wieder wir gehen
am besten mal rüber denn jetzt kommt
quasi so
landschaft und das ist mein persönliches
highlight so hier ist die stehlampe also
quasi das gegenstück zu meiner hänge
lampe ist ist auch für babbel ist und
nicht einfach so cool ja und jetzt sitze
ich quasi schon auf meinem riesen super
bzw wir auch der riesengroßen
wohnlandschaft das wichtigste war mir
eigentlich dass wir genug platz für die
ganze familie und das sie gemütlich ist
man sitzt nicht so tief drin aber auch
noch so tief dass man abends wirklich
hier quasi so halb liegen kann und filme
machen kann die farbe nennt sich samt
sand es gibt aber auch ganz viele
verschiedene farben warum habe ich mich
für die farbe entschieden ich finde man
kann richtig gut variieren ich kann zum
beispiel im winter andere vorhänge dran
machen und dann mit farben spielen und
das geht mit seiner farben bin ich ganz
gut ich war mehr tat sich nicht sicher
soll ich jetzt dort doch grün nehmen
oder nicht aber gut dass ich mich gegen
grünen entschieden habe und eben für
samt sand so hilft man nochmal ein
riesengroßes tablett aus holz das kann
man aber auch wegnehmen also es ist
jetzt nicht fest verankert aber ich
finde es ganz cool way kann man auch mal
glas wasser abstellen oder mal sein café
abstellen wenn man liegt vielleicht mal
popcorn daneben legen und daher ganz
praktisch das gleiche habe ich hier auch
noch mal so hier ist auch noch mal so
ein tablett das kann man quasi hier an
diese lehne dran machen das ist auch für
praktisch ansonsten habe ich hier noch
einen dünnen teppich gerade jetzt im
sommer also im winter überlege ich mir
so ein verschieben da noch hin zu machen
und zwei tische da habe ich einfach
drauf geachtet dass zum beispiel diese
füße sage ich mal auch matt und metall
sind alles quasi also auch die
tischbeine auch die stuhlbeine die sind
alle schwarz matt und das war mir
wichtig dass es halt weil das ist ja ein
raum man sieht auf einen blick alles das
ist dann tatsächlich auch passt hier
habe ich noch schöne bilder
da ist etwas persönliches da ist unter
anderem ein lieblings vers aber auch von
hamza und mir unser traum tag also die
islamische trauung das datum das habe
ich da noch mit reinschieben und das
hier habe ich mir bei adaptec aust und
dann ausgedruckt die ansonsten noch ein
paar so hochzeitsbilder und ein bisschen
deko und rechts habe ich dann auch noch
einen schönen spiegel hängen den spiegel
feier ist so hübsch ich finde ihn
einfach so schön und er seien auch
schwarz matt habe ich hier einfach noch
so eine pflanze stehen und ja eigentlich
fehlt jetzt nur noch quasi der bereich
da gucke ich nämlich direkt auf dem
fernseher das zeige ich euch kommen mit
beim fernseher habe ich ein ganz
schlichtes longboard hängen das hat er
auch füße ich hab dir aber weggenommen
und ich habe die montage mit gebucht das
heißt dass wird direkt montiert das ist
super macht und hat auch wieder schwarz
matte griffe und dann haben wir das war
ganz cool das hier ist übrigens eine
mietwohnung also es ist nicht gekauft
aber trotzdem hat mir super viel
mitspracherecht der vermieter hat zum
beispiel die idee gehabt hey lass uns
doch so eine dumme kuh
ist es zum einen also diese öffnung
quasi das ist noch mal so ein bisschen
tiefer hat in der fernseher hängt quasi
und dann ich finde dass das macht halt
optisch echt noch mal was aus und direkt
darüber haben wir eine klimaanlage das
gold wert in der küche ist ja auch eine
das heißt gerade im sommer kann man
einfach ganz entspannt hier sich
aufhalten und geht halt nicht ein in der
hitze
[Musik]
servicebüro wenn sie mal außerhalb
unserer geschäftszeiten hier morgen
männer stimmt tatsächlich öfters da als
das ist unser büro ich sage mal auch auf
ist für jeden
super wichtig dass mannschaft zu hause
schön einrichten wird haben sie und ich
lebe ja praktisch schon seit jahren im
hoffen wir dass er auch schon vor der
krise gemacht haben aber haben sie hat
es wirklich so weinreich davor war der
weiß nicht wie die und sänger verfolgen
wissen aus der vollversion schmalen raum
der ist da drüben mit ankleidezimmer
gemischt und jetzt hat er wirklich so
sein eigenes reich und das ist hammers
platz und ich sitze direkt gegenüber ja
wir sind verheiratet ja wir arbeiten
auch zusammen und wir sehen uns 24 7
trotzdem funktioniert das irgendwie
ich weiß nicht wie das funktioniert und
ich bin auch gerne deine arbeitskollegin
aber ich bin noch die wir dann ehefrau
hockey jetzt zeige ich euch hier mal
hier ist jetzt ein großer schrank da
haben wir die ganzen unterlagen
papierkram und so weiter drin und dann
noch so ein bisschen mit unseren eigenen
produkten dekorieren natürlich es ist ja
hier das büro und ich muss sagen wenn
ich das so immer auf einem blick auch
sehr dann wird man auch wo ist was wir
alles so schönes machen also wie viele
produkte ist mittlerweile einfach sind
und ja das fand ich auch ganz süß jetzt
haben sie noch ein bisschen equipment
und ich zeige euch am besten mal die
andere seite wir haben eigentlich alles
aus der gleichen serie das heißt einen
großen schrank ihn noch mal einen
kleinen und die zwei tischen die sind
aus der gleichen serie und das ist halt
passen ich habe mich für so ein helles
grau entschieden und für weiße
glasfronten das finde ich ganz elegant
und ja hier seht ihr zum beispiel da bin
ich auch ganz stolz drauf das ist die
fußball mannschaft die wir gesponsert
haben
es steht ihm richtig gut ne und dann
haben wir hier oben noch fotos das
wahrhaben dass idee fand ich auch ganz
cool ist hier einfach auch nochmal so
unsere drei lieblinge an der wand hängt
dann geht es eigentlich hier direkt
weiter mit dem tischen da sind wie
gesagt also unsere pcs ich habe mit pcs
seit kurzem bei unseren laptop
gearbeitet aber hamza hat dann gekommen
denn holt der 1 9 für sich und ich
kriege seinen alten und da kann ich auch
viel besser drauf also ich mache halt
auch ein rezept entwicklung ich stehe
auch viel in der küche ich mache aber
auch viel am pc unter anderem schneide
ich auch so sonder videos wie dieses
hier das schneide ich zum beispiel oder
die andere habe ich auch geschnitten
manche blogs schneidig und da ist so ein
pc halt immer besseren das gute ist halt
wir arbeiten parallel das heißt wir sind
besonders produktiv hier habe ich auch
so ein aufsteller hat den habe ich habe
tatsächlich selber in den kaufland
filialen nicht gesehen weil zu der zeit
war ich so einen stress ich konnte
einfach nicht hinnehmen und dann waren
diese blieb von kaufland und haben dort
herkommt und schicken würde 1 zu und
dadurch natürlich super stolz drauf und
das werde ich auch nie wegschmeißen
niemals auch wenn haben soll sagt wie
lange soll das denn hier jetzt noch
platz einnehmen hamza das bleibt für
mich hier ist auch noch mal so ein
offenes stylisches regal also ich finds
merkur was hat auch wieder schwarz matt
ist ihr merkt schon ich liebe schwarz
matte sachen
ich hab ich dich nicht so ausführen aber
in echt nix aus gehört aber im block
widmann zial du meintest auch ganz
ehrlich suche einfach aus ist mir egal
aber es ist doch schön geworden
schreibt mir doch mal in die kommentare
wie findet ja unsere einrichtung stil
würde mich auch mal interessieren ich
weiß geschmäcker sind verschieden aber
schreib doch mal gerne hier unten rein
ich habe hier natürlich auch noch mal
ein paar produkte hin getarnt dass es
zum beispiel müssen unsere veganen
samples also die lok ums kriegen wir
bald dann auch in vegan daher fahrzeug
100 helwig anzulocken da stehen haben
und das ist nicht immer naschen während
du arbeitest ich rühre die nicht an das
sind meine letzten drei samples ich
warten bis die lieferung da ist und das
war das büro ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt so
einen schönen großen einblick von mir
bekommen auf instagram sieht der halt
immer nur so ein paar sequenzen und
einfach nicht den ganzen raum ich kann
euch auch gerne in zukunft mitnehmen
wenn ich hier mal um der kuriere je nach
saison und ansonsten schreibe ich euch
bzw setzt euch einen link zu den ganzen
möbelstücken in die video beschreibung
weil ich weiß dass da natürlich auch
viele fragen aufkommen werden was vom
modell das genau ist und bevor ich euch
das jetzt hier im video sagen die mit
schreiben ist schaut einfach unten in
die video beschreibung ansonsten hoffe
ich das sehe bei meinem nächsten video
auch wieder mit am start seit und
wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen
tag tschüss